You guys are actually going to get
the ultimate hall pass
to explore what life would be like
with someone other than your spouse.
I am doing my breathing.
Guys, give me your rings.
Take it off.
Your marriage perhaps
doesn't have
maybe that fire that
it used to have,
that fuego, that pasión,
you know?
You guys ready to have some fun?
Yes!
Well, here they come.
This experience, I'm hoping,
will give a spark
back to my husband.
[IN SPANISH] I feel Richard does not protect
me and since that's what I need,
[IN SPANISH] this show is worth everything.
I think living with these guys
is going to be a fun experience.
Something will most likely happen,
just a matter of time.
How do you think your wife
would feel about the date?
Oh my God, she's 23.
[IN SPANISH] Why did you kiss him?
Can you explain it to me?
[IN SPANISH] Because I felt like it!
It is now your moment of truth.
Do you, in fact, have a
love for the ages,
or will you decide
to walk away?